veut-on d'un doumensonge ou d'une amère
vérité
celle-ci malheureusement est claire le
système des retraites par répartition
est menacé
faut-il donc le réformer dans la réponse
de notre groupe celle qui a rappelé le
président Marseille tout à l'heure est
clair et sans ambiguïté c'est oui d'un
système conçu
à l'origine avec quatre cotisants pour
un retraité ce ratio tombent aujourd'hui
à 1,7 cotisants pour un retraité c'est
un déséquilibre évident incontestable et
qui s'accroît avec l'espérance de vie
d'aucun pensent que les hommes mentent
les chiffres un peu moins le corps
conseille d'orientation des retraites
c'est soudainement retrouvé sous les
feux de la rampe des rapports en général
indigestes sont devenus malgré eux
livrent d'éveil pour pas dire de chevet
pour certains irresponsables politiques
car il s'agit bien d'irresponsabilités à
ne retenir du corps que le seul fait que
des dépenses soient sous contrôle
c'est négliger le sujet de la dette la
dette retraite est déjà très élevée 43
milliards portés par la Cadès c'est
négliger aussi que les déficits cumulés
selon le corps d'ailleurs
représenteront 150 milliards de dettes
nouvelles en 2030 alors fallait-il
réformer dès maintenant
nous répondons encore 800 hésiter en
matière climatique on parle volontiers
d'urgence de ce que nous laisserons à
nos enfants et petits-enfants il en est
de même pour les retraites et notamment
pour les jeunes qui croient de moins en
moins qu'ils en auront une
le Sénat dans sa sagesse d'ailleurs n'a
pas attendu l'agenda au gouvernementale
pour réformer il adopte depuis plusieurs
années le recul progressif de l'âge de
départ à 64 ans avec l'accélération de
la loi Touraine bien plus juste car
recul brutal à 65 ans
la réforme proposée est-elle adaptée
notre réponse est encore affirmative si
l'on accepte comme postulat de ne pas
augmenter les cotisations retraite afin
de ne pas
affaiblir pardon le pouvoir d'achat des
salariés pour lequel évidemment nous
sommes d'accord
mais en ce qui concerne la création
d'emplois j'en doute en effet admis
point de plus de cotisations employeur
représente 4 milliards et demi de
recettes en moyenne 225 euros par
salarié par an
c'est pour une entreprise de sens
salarié un peu moins qu'un poste de
travail
donc cette réforme est-elle
satisfaisante d'un point de vue
comptable oui d'un point de vue social
et politique on peut en débattre et
c'est bien cela d'ailleurs auquel nous
sommes conviés d'un point de vue social
les 17 milliards 7 dégagées en 2030
permettront de financer 6 milliards de
mesure de solidarité et d'un point de
vue politique l'évidence c'est que les
Français n'admettent pas le recul de
l'âge à 64 ans considérant à juste titre
que seuls les salariés sont mis à
contribution une autre solution serait
évidemment d'augmenter la taxation du
capital est-ce que c'est envisageable et
bien c'est une question que je pose au
gouvernement et à ceux qui seraient
tentés de prendre tout le plat dans leur
assiette pour citer la des pierres
au nom de la solidarité nationale il ne
me paraît ni outrageant ni indécent que
les bénéficiaires d'un CAC 40 au plus
haut actuellement accepte une
augmentation de la CSG sur le capital
un point supplémentaire rapporterait
amias 5 alors abordons maintenant
quelques articles rapidement ça lui ont
tout d'abord les propositions du
gouvernement pour tenter d'améliorer la
justice et l'équité du système
nous avons quelques questions parce que
certaines mesures pour certaines mesures
le diable on le sait se cache dans les
détails pour les petites retraites tout
le monde a retenu qu'il n'y aurait pas
de retraite à moins de 1200 euros mais
peu ont compris que cela concernait que
les carrières complètes alors une
suggestion celle de Lukas qui me paraît
intelligente et intelligible pourquoi ne
pas mettre un plancher à 75% du SMIC
soit 1000 euros pour les carrières
incomplètes
pour les carrières longues
le dispositif paraît serpenté de façon
erratique entre 43 et 44 ans de durée de
cotisation en fonction de l'entrée dans
la vie active il nous apparaît
nécessaire de lisser l'ensemble avec
donc des départs de 57 à 62 ans de quoi
ouvrir une fenêtre d'ailleurs de départ
de 57 à 64 ans chers aux économistes
Blanchard et Tyrol et beaucoup plus
jeune que juste qu'une borne unique de
départ à 64 ans
pour les seniors le gouvernement a
décidé de s'intéresser aux fins de
carrière mais je crains que l'index
Seigneur proposait ne soit guère
suffisant pour répondre à l'intention
qu'il manifeste il nous semble que cette
index doit être accompagné d'une prime à
l'embauche sorte de un seigneur une
solution et que pourquoi pas d'ailleurs
un CDI
senior et nous ne devrions pas faire
l'économie d'un bonus malus sur la base
de cette index pour favoriser le
maintien des seniors dans l'emploi
pour les droits familiaux nous
proposions donc avant la hache de
l'article 40 un départ anticipé à 62 ans
pour trois enfants et 63 ans pour deux
mais nous constatons aussi de fortes
disparité dans les droits familiaux la
réversion particulière ou 13 régimes
subsistent et qu'il sera nécessaire de
revoir dans la prochaine loi enfin
la pénibilité la Pénélope du travail que
l'on s'y arrête un petit peu plus nous y
sommes attentifs bien entendu nous
sommes attentifs à la réflexion aussi
sur le travail la nécessité de lui
donner plus de sens nous sommes aussi
tous tout aussi vigilant face à ceux qui
contesteraient la valeur du travail il
n'appartient pourtant pas à cette loi de
financement évidemment de la sécurité
sociale de traité de ce sujet beaucoup
trop complexe où tous les points de vue
divers chevaux suivant évidemment le
point dont de duquel on se place du
point de vue de quel on se place alors
faisons venons-en à ce qui nous
préoccupe vraiment c'est à dire réparer
l'usure professionnelle la loi dans ce
domaine est généreuse elle prend en
compte les trois autres critères
d'ergonomiques qui donneront lieu à un
suivi médical c'est bien mais il nous
paraît nécessaire de compléter ce bilan
avec un bilan de compétences pour
envisager sérieusement enfin un mot pour
conclure sur ce qui nous tient à cœur à
nous Centris le dialogue social nous
regrettons qu'il est tourné court que
certains partenaires sociaux et
responsables politiques et refusé
d'emblée le diagnostic du corps du corps
avant d'y consentir que d'autres est
crus que la désinformation est listerie
pouvait remplacer le débat aussi ce vrai
débat que chacun mérite et qui pourra je
l'espère se nouer ici au Sénat aucune
réponse n'est faite pour l'éternité
plusieurs dates jalonnent deux décennies
de réforme des retraites si ajoutera
sans aucun doute 2023 et peut-être aussi
2027 avec la réforme présidentielle pour
cela nous pensons qu'il est bon qui est
une clause de revoyure ou plutôt un
bilan d'étape produit par la Cour des
comptes afin d'assurer peut-être la
sérénité du débat qui suivra comme celui
qui je l'espère pourra se dérouler ici
demain dans cette assemblée merci
beaucoup